I have a problem with New Year's resolutions,...
...not because they often fail or because they're too difficult,...
...and not because I'm bad at them either.
I mean, I've only been alive for four New Year's!
No, I have a problem with resolutions because people think that that's it.
It's the one time to change.
Now, don't get me wrong, we definitely all need change.
I have no idea how to ride a bicycle,...
...and my little brother has no idea what a toilet is for.
And some of you, yeah, you should probably get out of the house more,...
...but one big decision probably isn't going to do it.
Sorry!
So, now what?
Flush your resolutions down the toilet?
The one my little brother can't use?
Of course not!
Keep your resolutions but go easy on yourself.
Will you change?
Maybe.
But it probably won't happen in one big moment.
It'll happen in thousands of little moments.